good morning Hank it's Thursday October
30th that means it's show-and-tell
Thursday the day where I show you real
presents that real nerdfighters have
given me on my tour Hank broadly
speaking nerdfighters have been giving
me two kinds of presents the first is
the kind that's related to my book like
this dreidel which as you will no doubt
recall is what they called a minivan I'm
not good at spinning dreidels
and this black Santa who on his left
hand is reminding us do not forget to be
awesome
also this real-life minivan that I got
in Phoenix let me look
nope no cracks must be a sealed vessel
the second kind of presents I've been
receiving stuff related to nerdfighters
like this actual hat that came from
someone who actually works at the actual
Ning I was signing books last night and
she was like hi I'm Laura I'm from the
Ning and I was like yeah I know
everybody's from the Ning I'm from the
Ning captain cockatiels from the Ning
tons of people are from the name and she
was like no I work at Ning comm the
company and I was like oh my god was
like a celebrity sighting like the
person who made it possible for us to
have a Ning was just standing there with
a free hat for me look Hank military
insignia and check out this nice
nerdfighter bracelet or alternately a
necklace for an extremely small necked
person also using some kind of magic
spongy material I've never seen before a
nerdfighter made me both a puppy sized
elephant and a little Willie with a cast
ello bubble the nerdfighting puppy tank
I kind of miss Willie also I can't wait
to get home to him and I'll tell you why
it's not because I miss cleaning P off
the hardwood floor or even because I
missed the constant barking it's because
a nerdfighter in Los Angeles made me a
puppy sized elephant costume for Willie
you put his legs through here and then
he's an elephant and he walks around and
he's got a drunk and he's got this
little head so he'll just like walk
around and it'll be like my name is
Willie I'm gonna pee on some stuff
I mean seriously Hank how awesome is
this I mean Hank that costume is so
awesome I have to have a conversation
with a finger puppet monkey about it
isn't that awesome yes I know can you
get over it no hey by the way is it hard
having this banana that's like
perpetually close to your mouth that you
can never eat for the
your wife yeah it sucks and finally Hank
I'd just like to share with you this
page from a fictional version of the
National Inquirer in which Oprah is
pwned I don't know if I'm saying I'll
destroy you or if she's saying I'll
destroy you but I do know that you look
funny in that tomato costume also right
down at the bottom beside Nevel obtains
godlike powers is Margo flips out over
tell-all book it's just so awesome and
that's not even to mention all the peeps
I've gotten or the hundreds of other
made of awesome presents I've gotten
from nerdfighters thank you all so so
much Hank thanks for being awesome I'll
see you tomorrow and then I'll see you
on Saturday in real life because we're
getting ready for the great American
tour to nerdfighting 2008 I'm so excited
best wishes